hi I'm Kevin and this is a cute little
guppy in a fishbowl and in a matter of
minutes you'll discover why this cute
little guppy in a fishbowl holds the
secret to living the rest of your life
free from disease illness or infection
there is a billion dollar industry in
scamming seniors and people with chronic
incurable diseases it's a scam that has
only grown with the Internet but it's
sort of hidden now because it operates
not on public websites but you have
generally are invited to these webinars
via email lists that you get on because
you're looking up for medical advice you
know this that or the other and dubious
doctors who could rail against Big
Pharma are happy to tell your older
loved ones that there is a cure for
their incurable disease in order to
siphon money from their bank accounts to
the scammers bank accounts this is
something that I recently learned about
I'm sort of furious so without further
ado let's get into the guppy cure
because we got to start somewhere and I
think I think the best way to start is
just to throw you in to one of these
scams to give you an idea of what's
going on believe it or not this odd
little picture of a guppy in a fish bowl
is the answer to achieving limitless
health and curing all disease even the
most severe and incurable ones that
doctors have turned their back on and
become completely disease-free for the
rest of your life
warning I may be forced by the powers
that be to take this free video down if
you come back tomorrow and this
presentation is no longer free don't say
I didn't warn you watch it right now
guys it might go away the powers that be
oh my god let me guess let me guess
at what the powers are be gonna be Big
Pharma let me guess big farm those
greedy pharma guys right remember I'm
about to share a health secret that has
been proven to cure if not provide
desperately needed relief to any and all
disease illness or Elmo
States of America you know this may
sound impossible right now your doctor
friends and family will be shocked
they'll be shocked how much your bank
account has been whittled down by our
health scams how suddenly even tumors
and cancer cells can begin to melt away
by the way do you like how it says watch
this short controversial video before
this gets banned let me just tell you
right now this video is not short we're
gonna be just like kind of skimming
through some of it cuz it gets
ridiculous and as you've already noticed
they jump around a lot like they repeat
themselves a lot so it takes them a
while to get to the actual point oh man
one of the things that I fight fight
with is some of these bigger scams
they're so obviously scams to the people
who are not their target demographic and
so it's easy to dismiss these things
says oh yeah who would fall for that but
if you think that you're not the target
for these scams the target is not you
know 25 year-olds usually that's mostly
my demographic on coffee Silla eighteen
to thirty thirty year old males you know
whatever it is it's it's 60 year olds
seven year olds people who are dying who
want a cure that's the target of this
okay so if you can put yourself in that
kind of mind frame you're desperate you
don't have any hope this all of a sudden
looks a lot less this game it looks a
little more compelling when you were
younger you would maybe get a cold or
even the flu but you would recover like
it was nothing you were invincible then
you got older you noticed more people
you know developing cancer or even
tragically dying from cancer the truth
is your body already has the power to
kill any harmful germ virus bacteria or
dysfunction and anyone can release this
miraculous healing power for themselves
oh okay okay there it is hold on
actually I want to point something out
to you because something I've watched so
many of these by this point which we're
gonna watch together later on but one
thing I want to tell you guys about that
if someone says this you should just run
in the other direction
people natural people are always talking
about you have a natural healing
mechanism in your body which is to some
extent true but they always claim that
it's like it's just waiting to be
unlocked like it can cure anything like
oh you have stage
or cancer well you must not have a lost
natural healing mechanism have you
thought about that so well one thing I
would notice how he's already setting it
up oh it's it's your natural healing
mechanic it already exists we're just
gonna unlock it right
imagine that cute little guppy you saw
in the beginning of this presentation
like all fish it breathes water into its
gills and takes the oxygen out of the
water inside its body but what if the
water was polluted what if it was filled
with deadly or harmful bacteria they
would go right into the little guppy
right so just curing the guppy is not
enough we need to clear the water we've
gone to Prattville okay yeah so we go
through more of the stuff they play more
on your emotions you know all this stuff
and basically this guy says disease and
oxygen cannot coexist which is an
interesting development for biology I'm
not sure medical doctors knew that that
oxygen and germs cannot coexist
fascinating stuff but he says look you
need to oxygenate yourself to protect
yourself and the way to do that is if
you get his little book is a hydrogen
peroxide therapy now this is the new
wave this is the bleach new wave right
you guys thought drinking bleach was
dangerous and cool it's not anymore now
it's all about drinking hydrogen
peroxide yes that's right 35% diluted
hydrogen peroxide so here's the thing
you can't go out and run by hydrogen
peroxide from the store because it's 3%
but it has some stabilizers in it which
means you can't drink it so these people
this person says you should get food
grade 35% hydrogen peroxide which is
incredibly dangerous and can poison you
if ingested and you basically become a
little chemist right you get your little
this is tea but this would be water
you'd fill it up with water and you'd a
little dropper you get some latex gloves
they say actually they say put on your
latex gloves note it is not essential to
use latex gloves if you handle the 35
percent hydrogen peroxide carefully
hilarious but I do that little burn
when you drip some on your hand gives
you the added motivation to use them
next time you decide let's be clear ya
need to use gloves when you handle
thirty five percent hydrogen peroxide
but anyway they want you to become a
part-time little chemist and dilute this
yourself you you want to put twenty five
little drops of your super highly
concentrated hydrogen peroxide right in
there and then drink it you drink the
hydrogen peroxide now the FDA would tell
you that there's no proven benefit to
this and that you they've actually
issued warnings to people who are
claiming that this will cure disease but
does that stop Keith Richardson no
because he wants to take your grandma's
money and this is how he's gonna do it
right this is how he's gonna do it like
not only is this stuff not true it's
dangerous man
like check this out you may experience
flu or cold like symptoms this is called
a healing crisis your body will be
trying to expel dead formerly diseased
cells and this may put you into an acute
health crisis this can be easily
misinterpreted as an illness and cause
people to stop treatment
do not stop it means it's working this
is a very temporary situation that could
potentially rid you of a debilitating
disease you may be a little
uncomfortable for a short time but the
payoff is worth it that's right when
you're chugging that thirty five percent
hydrogen peroxide or your little diluted
chemist mix as an untrained amateur home
chemist you know don't don't feel bad if
all of a sudden you feel brain fog even
though drinking hydrogen peroxide
undiluted has been known to cause you
know brain damage don't stop it may just
be the healing working right it may just
be the healing working in your body you
know and make sure granny has those
glasses when she's working the
eyedropper because you don't want her to
MIT mistake 25 drops 50 drops
accidentally pouring the thing in you
know might be life or death but who
cares let's just throw that into
granny's hands right that's not a bad
thing and then it's like when you have a
health crisis that you feel is too
uncomfortable you may choose to stay at
the same level of hydrogen peroxide
drops on the regimen so don't go down
don't stop
before continuing upward after the
crisis passes I mean I don't know how to
explain how dangerous this advice is to
just be throwing into people's hands as
some kind of miracle medical cure it's
so embarrassing to leverage people's
fear of Big Pharma and say oh the
medical industry would never allow this
they're too greedy and then to sell your
book for 3995 right oh this guy has a
duty to show it to you doesn't he he's
got a duty he feels obligated to help
you and I think you'll see why I feel a
sense of duty to share it with you he
just wants to help you know it's
ulterior motive he wants to heal your
granny your grandpa
guys it's just sick and you know what
it's happening right here in the United
States these kind of scams are happening
here not in India not in Pakistan it's
not it's not a scam happening from
another country they were happening here
and people are making millions of
dollars from your loved ones who are
sick and desperate and weak so uh man I
want to call awareness to this industry
people don't know that this industry is
so rampant they don't know all the
copywriters that are working night and
day to write these sales letters like
that's a video sales letter we just
watched in order to psychologically
manipulate old people desperate people
fat people anybody with a problem into
thinking that they are a $40 ebook away
a $50 ebook away you know a $90
supplement away from being cured and
they're not and the fact that this has
gone on so long without being called out
is is a shame so we're gonna change that
right here on coffee Scylla
I'll see you guys soon whisky Flyboys
crowd fratricide this don't you know
that you could have died shut it down
boys and losses at all monsters were
walking earth and she's got red lipstick
Oh shoes
[Music]
see the new house sounds
she's got an old left kids she's been to
you she's got blood in her eyes and her
eyes to you she's got a pug
in our eyes for you